has doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness changed the marvel cinematic
universe forever or are we just dreaming
keep watching for the terrifying truth
for much of its run time doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness is exactly
the kind of fever dream only the
combination of sam raimi's horror
sensibilities and the trippiest big
budget corner of the marvel cinematic
universe can deliver though doctor
strange and his various allies and
antagonists face plenty of oddness and
terror in cold daylight dreams are a
surprisingly big part of the movie
every night
i dream the same dream
in fact some of the movies creepiest
moments come when powerful magic users
deploy a technique called dreamwalking
to possess their alternate universe
counterparts dreamwalking is a dangerous
dark hold technique that wreaks havoc on
both the user and it seems everyone in
their vicinity when darkhold corrupted
wanda maximoff overwhelms her illuminati
universe variant she becomes an even
more unstoppable horror movie monster
easily tearing her way through the
illuminati's defenses and killing the
vast majority of the group in
increasingly inventive grim ways later
strange manages to make dreamwalking
even more horrifying when he possesses
the dead body of his variant harnesses
the power of lost souls and attacks
wanda as a zombie wizard with an army of
dark spirits both of these sequences are
as grim as they're exciting yet somehow
these elaborate rainy moments aren't
even the scariest dream-related
revelation the movie has in store see dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
reveals the truth about the nature of
dreams in the mcu and the truth is
nothing short of terrifying it turns out
that in the mcu your dreams actually
happen to you somewhere in the
multiverse even sorcerers supreme old
and new can learn new things and when
multiverse traversing america chavez
tells strange and wong that the dream
the former was having was actually real
to the strange variant who died in the
opening scene of the movie they're
somewhat taken aback by the news in fact
wang is pretty concerned when he finds
out that his dream of being chased by a
clown in a tragically undressed state
has actually happened to some poor wong
variant out there because the whole your
dreams are real concept apparently isn't
unnerving enough on its own the movie
also gives a very concrete example of a
common bad dream and how it might play
out in the mcu multiverse when doctor
strange encounters a darkhold corrupted
variant of himself who has a rather
questionable hobby of killing alternate
universe stranges the variant reveals
that most dreams of falling that the
main strange has ever had were likely
caused by the darkhold strange killing
other strange variants in ways that
presumably involve great heights sounds
like a real
nightmare
not all multiverse dreams of course are
nightmares but that doesn't mean they're
any less heartbreaking for instance
wanda is able to confirm the multiversal
existence of her supposedly non-existent
children because she keeps dreaming of
them given that the majority of the
movie's characters are magic users
multiverse experts or both there's a
chance that the whole your dreams are
actually happening to another version of
you thing might be exclusive to people
who are in tune with the strange unseen
forces that govern the magical side of
the mcu however as long as that's not
clear the viewer can't help but think
that every single bad dream a
character's ever had in the mcu is just
a vision of their variant having a
really really bad time this by proxy
implies that the mcu is an even wilder
place than you've seen so far which is
saying something considering that doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
alone introduces viewers to things like
an animated universe and some sort of
cubist nightmare universe every time the
mega franchise's heroes and villains go
to sleep and dream the uneasy dreams
their stressed brains no doubt conjure
up they're actually watching the wild
and awful adventures of their
multiversal variants that's just the
super folks too if the same applies to
the billions of people living on earth
alone this means that any and all truly
mind-boggling dreams these countless
people are able to conjure up are on the
table imagine how many truly weird
dreams fit in there and what kind of odd
universes they might reveal it's
entirely possible that by the simple
dream revelation alone the mcu has
stealthily opened the door to stories
that are so weird they make even doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
look like a walk in the park
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one